the jurgen experience
the us is in a recession at the moment
but it's not allowed to be called a
recession
well the government's trying to not call
it a recession but it's wikipedia
article
got changed you see this really
oh dude no
so they redefined recession yep so
recession used to be two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth
right
not anymore not on wikipedia when was
this jamie get the get the wikipedia
thing up because this is wild how long
ago they changed this weekend oh god uh
i saw it got well i saw it got locked
because people were [ __ ] with it is
what i read but i don't know how much of
that was but this is the definition when
you type in google which is the same
thing
so a period of temporary economic
decline during which trade and
industrial activity are reduced
generally identified by a fall in gdp in
two successive quarters so
in google it's still the same in
wikipedia let's look at what it what it
says
recession is a business cycle
contraction where there's a general
decline in economic activity recessions
generally occur
when there is a widespread spread drop
in spending and or
an adverse
demand shock this may
be triggered by various events such as
financial crisis and external trade
shock and adverse supply shock bursting
okay here it is a recession is defined
by the national bureau of economic
research has a significant decline in
economic activity spread across the
market lasting more than a few months
normally visible in real gdp real income
employment industrial production and
wholesale retail sales so
in the uk it's the in the uk it's
defined as that in uk it's defined as a
negative economic growth for two
consecutive quarters so
so that's what's changed that the united
states used to define it as two
consecutive quarters and now we don't
anymore and people have pulled it up on
the archive so a bunch of advisors
economic advisers have got quotes of
them saying what a recession is
especially when donald trump was in
office there is a recession that's
coming negative gdp growth for two
consecutive quarters right and then this
weekend people are asking them are we in
a recession because the second quarter
uh economics just came out and it's
0.9 decline again have you seen the
white house press secretary define the
economy as being strong and the the best
economy we've had in over a decade have
you seen her do that no it's hilarious
it's like the wildest gaslighting
because she's doing all of these
political hand maneuvers that people do
you know those moves that people do with
their hands when they're talking and
they're trying to display like
confidence and control and there's like
it's it's literally like political
pantomiming it's it's weird to watch in
the political tai chi yeah it's weird to
watch because it's like sleight of hand
it's like it's very bizarre you think
they've been trained in that some
neuro-linguistic programming if you put
your hands here when you're saying this
sort of a thing blah blah blah i don't
know if they're
there's clearly an
indication that that's
what you would do if you were trained
but i think it's more mimicking
it's mimicking like the great
presidents and the great politicians who
have done these very specific things
like bill clinton famously used to do
this thing with his fingers we'd take
his thumb and do this and just
so it's not aggressive and violent
because you can't really hit someone
with this
but if you were doing this yeah it'd be
a problem that's problematic that's
angry right with the pointing the finger
the fist is a sign of violence but this
thing is this weird
like a mushy
so the bizarre thing about the
recession situation is the fact that it
doesn't matter what you call it right
you can call it [ __ ] paradise if you
want but it's still [ __ ] right like all
of the criteria
of what's happening yes indicates a
recession yes and the reason obviously
is you've got midterms coming up and you
need to make sure that is in a recession
is not something that can be thrown at
the democrats yes right it's a
protectionist strategy
yes so no don't use that word well it's
not it's not because it's not defined in
that way right that's not the accepted
definition right it was until very very
very recently that's wild well that's
gaslighting that and just that alone you
know is
people would think that it's trivial
because they are
talking about
this economic downturn
but it's not trivial because we've
always used that term recession and
we've always used that term to define
whether or not the economic policies
that are currently in place and whether
or not the management the government has
done a good job
of making sure that the economy stays in
a good place that's they definitely
haven't done that so in order to escape
that in you know that sort of
distinction they're literally changing
the definition which is terrible and it
should be pushed back against in a big
way it should it should be something
that people get angry about like hey
you're [ __ ] with definitions in order
to pretend that you're doing a good job
well the reason that you attach a
sequence of letters to
something right is to represent what
that thing is you don't change reality
by changing what those words actually
mean right
but if you can't control the economy you
might as well just control the language
and hope for the best god
what a bunch of weasels
dude it's wild but again this is this is
i think because
everybody's opinions and their words now
are what everyone's judged on not their
deeds right we used to be judged on our
deeds because they were the things with
the most obvious but now because social
media is one of the primary forms of
communication people are judged on their
opinions and their words far more and
what that means is that your opinion is
actually and the language specifically
that you use
is
it's way more important than actually
what's happening in the world and if
that's the case what it means is that
language should be the focus why
wouldn't i lexically try and do some
brazilian jiu jitsu to [ __ ] around with
this a little bit of semantic [ __ ]
why not well because that's going to
actually change the thing that most
people are taking notice of and also
there's a concept called two-step flow
theory and what it says is that there
are precious few original thinkers in
the world and because most people feel
like they have to have an opinion on
everything because that's the world that
we live in at the moment but very few
people can be bothered to do original
thought and do the research
people just take on the opinion of
whoever their favorite thought leader is
so you could basically argue that the
culture war is largely two armies of
npcs being ventriloquized by a handful
of actual thinkers above them
that's a great way to look at it and
that is kind of what's going on with a
great majority of people or a large
number of people i don't know if it's a
majority but it's enough to make noise
it's enough to
show you that there's a real problem
with ideologies and with tribalism
because that's what people
gravitate towards they gravitate towards
a group of people that they feel like
they can fit into and then they can
adopt those patterns of thinking and
those thoughts
and instead of coming up with their own
opinions they form this sort of
conglomeration of other people's
opinions and then they fiercely defend
them